our family wasn't really religious at
all like my mom was like Christian but
my dad would be like don't believe any
of that [__]
[Laughter]
a man of Florida has been arrested after
he allegedly shot his Pastor cousin huh
during an argument regarding Heaven and
Hell oh my God that's the fastest way to
settle it that's right well you're gonna
find out brother go find out it's always
good intentions so he killed the pastor
right he shot his passion shot the
pastor one who's also his cousin yeah
he's going to heaven brother so a 26
year old atheist kashonda Smith got into
an argument with his second cousin Jimmy
mcgally following a funeral for their
family oh [__] at the funeral yeah
following following the funeral I don't
know Hyman please guys right there yeah
uh police were dispatched over to
Jacksonville Florida on Saturday because
a report of a person being shot had been
filed report explained investigation
revealed that the victim Jimmy mcgally
and the suspect kashonda Smith became
involved in an argument after a funeral
for a family member regarding Heaven and
Hell the suspect did not believe in God
and the victim was a pastor who is
trying to witness it to him and the
argument became heated and the Smith
went outside in Anger as other family
members attempted to calm him down
report claims magali age 46 was then
shot by Miss Smith as he exited the
residence a report goes on to save the
family detained Ms Smith until cops
arrived and he was arrested and did he
say what he told me to do it he wanted
to see God I don't think that's what he
said but you know that would have been a
good Alibi yeah it'd be like well we
were experimenting he told me to do it
he told me to do it that guy's anger
management issues man oh man because
after a funeral I thought it wasn't
anger I thought it was good intentions
have him find out it was for science
yeah
or religion Christian Science Christian
Science Christian science science on his
end religion on the other have you guys
seen those Christian Science buildings
yeah what is it I don't have no idea
what that is what is Christian Science I
have no idea but I just see it all over
it was a science of God it's reading
room yeah and it would just be a
be a Christian Science yeah is there
science different just imagine a guy
with
I'm guessing their science says that the
the world started 4 000 years ago
but do their magnets work the way our
magnets do good question holy magnets
they're not even called a bunch of
burning bushes over there dude that's
what they're doing yeah yeah they're
trying to boost looking at holy water
under a microscope hide if they're
trying to recreate Bible things
like watch this bush yeah check it's
gonna go on fire oh look at that when
you get holy water it has to go through
Christian Science because when you look
in it has to have little crosses
beakers are just glasses they're like
this is holy water
um my Google search of the definition of
what Christian Science is is the beliefs
and practices of the Church of Christ
scientists a Christian sect founded by
Mary Baker Eddie and oh so it's just a
straight up other religion Christian
scientists and members hold that only
God and the mind have Ultimate Reality
and that sin and illness are Illusions
which can be overcome by prayer and
faith I agree I'm becoming one what if
they're like Christian geology and like
Christian biology and all these other
offsets Christian kung fu yeah that'll
be sick you're like what is this a whole
other language yeah dude so is that
that's another denomination I guess so
yeah Christian Science a set of beliefs
and practices associated with the
members of the Church of Christ comma
scientists can't be any weirder than
seven-day Adventists you guys should
convert just check it out I mean I feel
like it's a lateral move it's a lateral
movement you just do you ever visit any
church stuff or yeah you do if if like
there's an event or something yeah I
went to my first Catholic Church uh
service oh yeah how'd you like it it was
it was crazy it was like it was very uh
is it because Tiff is Catholic well a
family friend they're a Catholic and
their mother passed away and then we did
the whole like um I guess they do the
funeral days I'm gonna [__] butcher
this so I apologize in advance and
everything was in Spanish so I didn't
know what the [__] was going on try your
best but they do like I think they do 10
days of prayers after like uh somebody
passes what do they say in the prayer oh
dude it's like a lot of spirits
are they are they speaking in Latin and
stuff no they're speaking of Spanish but
they're doing their prayers and they're
saying it over and over again
[Laughter]
what are some other Spanish phrases oh
they started off
I remember
Feliz Navidad but you know you know
you know
I've watched Nacho Libre before I've
been into a Catholic Ceremony yeah so
the whole time I was just giggling and
it was at a funeral dude that was my
first Catholic thing too it was at a
funeral it was like a circle Oh I
thought you could say it was nachos but
then they kept they kept doing the thing
where like they would pray and then
everybody would and I don't know they're
calling response stuff yeah yeah they
keep standing up and then I'm like get
up I'm like hella late and then
everyone's doing this and I was like do
I do that I just do it yeah no one
taught me yeah exactly so I don't know
what the [__] is going on
Blasphemous and [__] yeah and they keep
standing up and I'm like late I'm like
[__] and I'm trying to like catch the
patterns of singing okay they said that
so that means we stand up now and then I
was like okay stand up okay I gotta wait
so I was like missing the patterns
you're like Eddie Murphy and coming to
America when he goes to the game
because like we didn't we our family
wasn't really religious at all like my
mom was like Christian but my dad would
be like don't believe any of that [__]
no way
[Laughter]
my
mom wasn't really like super religious
either he's like a part-time Christian
yeah I don't even know I wouldn't even
say she like would say she was really
religious bass probably yeah yeah yeah
and uh so my dad would always just be
like yeah don't believe me that [__]
when I when he took me up nudging you
and your mom's talking yeah and like
when they brought me to a Christian
School like for like two years I don't
know what the [__] was going on I had
any idea but anyway so at the service
like all the ceremonies that they did
like all the the guy with the swinging
chain and the smoke coming up oh that's
cool yeah bro like there's go go from
freaking oh see that's Kill Bill I
always missed about see I wish our
religion had more like swag a little bit
Yeah more props dude SDA is like so
boring bro because like even protest or
the other denominations still have Vans
they'll have the mega churches ours was
so boring because you can't show off so
then Catholics have like the [__] old
school tradition and it's a beautiful
Church dying Jesus and like all this
crazy [__] like he's like it's like it
looks cool like The Branding is anytime
somebody comes in with a little [__]
like smoking yeah a little smoke chain
and [__] and then they have different
outfits for different levels and [__]
yeah they would change Cardinals yeah
that's like someone's uncle and [__]
just in a suit that's right especially
have you guys been to a [__] like
cathedral in Europe yeah
yeah I meant to [__] wow the [__] out
of you right you're beautiful you're
crazy or whatever like uh we went to a
mass so they specifically have the at
the time where like the sun comes up and
then it goes through like that little
hole or whatever the middle of the
building and then boom crazy ass [__]
Sunbeam like in the middle of the
[__] in the front yeah it feels holy
yeah it feels holy already then when the
[__] comes with The Swinging
and that's like a tattoo on everybody
somehow yeah you're like oh my god I
think I'm [__] Catholic holy [__]
in the corner with like A's machine
a 20K light in the top background action
yeah and they have like statues and
paintings that are hundreds of years
yeah and then you're just like yo that's
the history yeah yeah yeah I saw this
[__] doing a sermon this Fool's
book was like
[Laughter]
and then you go to a church in a strip
mall and [__] and you're like man this
is right next to [__] Ross and like
come on go to church in Canoga Park I
know when I was like you know growing up
SDA they kind of like condition you as a
sort of rag on Catholics they rag on
everybody like they basically have ways
of making fun of every other religion
for being wrong like a Sunday Catholics
especially yeah like I was 17 I was
dating a girl I was Catholic we went to
church together in uh it was Temple City
or something and then the whole time
like my first time in a Catholic Church
all like I know about everything they
already do because I I know it through
making Duncan on them yeah they talk so
as I'm sitting there like I was like so
[__] it was just watching all this [__]
and then every time they do the chances
like oh yeah okay yeah yeah
sarcastically saying it like so
disrespectful she was like stop and I
was like what dude dude they guys are
the wrong religion yeah I'm such an
[__] they do that the cracker thing
right where you eat the body of Christ
the communion yeah yeah and then like
everyone lines up and I was like I was
looking at him and I was like yeah I was
like dude I was like do I go up and then
my mother-in-law's like nah you haven't
had your first communion so you can't go
dude how many I ate so many crackers
and then also everything too is like in
Spanish so I'm kind of like in and out I
hear a couple words so I'm like I don't
know what the [__] is kind of going on
and then everyone turns around and then
they go like oh hello oh yeah did the
peace be with you yeah and I'm like so
high and then I shake their hands and I
was like and then my wife's like you
gotta say hi to the people behind you
and I was like oh hello hello
be with you and I was like that's kind
of cool I like that part that was my
favorite part they do that at every
church that is fine no it was cool but
when we have communion we wash each
other's feet that is the dumbest one bro
yeah
and then and this is where our feet
fetishes start I use the pastor doesn't
put the the biscuit in your mouth
everyone has a little biscuit in a
Welch's grape juice because we don't
drink wine and then when they say go you
[__] eat it yeah for me I was the
impatient kid I'm like now and Mama's
like no not yet now she goes no not yet
and then she'll catch me you [__]
nibbling on it wow it's all wet it's
licking it like I'm not eating it I'm
just licking it I'm tasting the body of
Christ
[Music]
foreign